can't believe it's come to this hi I'm
Naji and I'm an underperforming fantasy
player
hi I mean what does Magic Johnson know
about winning anyway I told y'all I
don't belong here I was a pro bowler me
too say it with me everyone nobody cares
about the welcome and believe it or not
I used to be just like you I once got
benched for John Wolford true and now
I'm a straight baller hey I'm just blue
collar Kenny picket just a lunch PA and
jeans fella I was lucky enough to make
it out of the pit lost a lot of good men
lately Deonte cam but hey that's just
life down of the Ste yard I don't trust
myself to leave home because that's the
only place I can perform I took too much
money from some man you do not want to
upset and now I'm getting all sorts of
threats so we pull up to this club in a
Bea Jimmy we're supposed to talk about
our struggles oh am I struggling
sometimes the other rookies force me to
the bottle and the stoud goes wild hey
be careful and
I used to be Joe shyy I thought I was
invincible but then you know you get
hammered and Cleaveland once and it
becomes a habit next thing you know
you're getting blown out by the Titans
hey tell me shasty are you a praying man
you know you can't let people down if
everyone thinks you're just a little
stinker it's just for so long I've acted
really cool all the time and sometimes
Joe burrow
hurts scars guard I'm struggling and I
don't know what to do the Hey Joe I need
to ride home from my hot seat
[Music]
meeting I grew up with small town
American values sock hop on a Friday
church on Sunday but all that's gone now
down in the trenches the American way is
dead instead it's the Canada Way the M
Canada away it makes no sense to me at
all